[Music]
welcome back to Hannity a partial
government shutdown looms ahead of
Friday's deadline the Democrat hysterics
have already begun Republicans offered
to compromise on the amount of funding
for the wall but the Democrats
immediately rejected that deal earlier
tonight President Trump tweeted quote
the Democrats are saying loud and clear
that they do not want to build a
concrete wall but we are not building a
concrete wall we are building
artistically designed steel slats so
that you can easily see through it it
will be beautiful and at the same time
give our country the security that our
citizens deserve it will go up fast and
save us billions of dollars a month once
completed joining us now with reaction
Fox News contributor Charles hurt GOPAC
chairman David develop and former
Clinton pollster and Fox News
contributor Doug Schon okay Doug now you
were laughing here now the the wall with
the beautiful slants are you questioning
whether we're actually going to get that
I don't think we're gonna get the wall I
mean I think the deal that should have
been done last week was the 1.6 billion
in border security fund the government
and move forward I think this is frankly
a setback for the cause of border
security and building the wall and also
a setback for democracy because the fact
that we can't fund the government and I
understand it's only a partial shutdown
right face but this is pathetic well but
you know what it's this isn't Trump's
fault I mean at the end of the day David
evelle I mean what we're talking about
is border security which has been kicked
down the road since actually I think
1986 but you know last I remember is
2006 and you know now what we've got a
shoe myrrh and Pelosi saying it's a
non-starter it's not happening
you're not getting the wall are we
getting the wall to your point there
judge that here you have a preview of
what the next two years is going to be
like well over the last two years we had
10 Senate Democrats in states that
President Trump won it was in their
interest to find common ground
with the president going into the 2020
elections there's two Doug Jones of
Alabama and Gary Peters of Michigan
there are less Democrats now willing to
work with the President on border
security on health care on the economy
why because it's in their interest to
obstruct and investigate and ultimately
seek to impeach the president you know
Charles the the the idea of the 1.6
billion from I think it was last week
that you know the Dems shot down and now
what we've got is the president through
Sarah Sanders suggesting that there is
money from other departments that can be
transferred so that he can build the
wall specifically from homeland security
and I believe the Pentagon is that is
that viable well I think that if you
talk to people you know that have
studied this for a long time and as you
point out the judge this has been this
is a problem that has been kicked down
the road since 1986 lawmakers in
Washington refused to fix the problem
that they promised to fix back then but
funding the wall has never been the real
big problem here and the real problem is
the will to actually do the hard work of
putting up a wall and and taking those
votes what the only thing we have found
out in the last two weeks is that
Democrats that are coming in to control
the house and the Senate in Congress
have vowed to shut the government down
instead of doing something about fixing
the border and whether you call it a
wall or a fence or what or the president
Trump's a wonderful description of it
through those tweets you just read
whatever you call it it is a barrier
that prevents people from illegally
crossing into the United States and
Democrats have made it very clear that
they are on the side of opposing that
and President Trump and Republicans have
made it very clear they're on the side
of supporting that and even Democrats
who support it say the 1997 the 2006
fence Act which did basically the same
thing which was to build a barrier to
keep people from sneaking into the
country Italy
even a lot of those Democrats have now
been pulled by the left wing of their
party over into this no borders anti ice
sanctuary city crowd that opposes doing
anything about the border and you know
Doug the the the idea of a a wall secure
fence from 2006 you had Schumer Pelosi
Obama they were all you know singing the
cheers of it the American people are not
stupid they are in favor of a border
they understand we need to be a
sovereign nation in essence what they're
saying is we're going to obstruct we're
proud to obstruct and they're almost
going against the American people as
well there's one other component of this
you haven't mentioned judges we have 11
million people who are here illegally we
need a pathway to citizenship and a wall
we need border security we need a
compromise and that's what politics is
about when you have divided government
which we will have in a couple of weeks
and that's what the president did when
he offered daca to 1.8 million daca kids
which is double what keep negotiating
what he was negotiating a good-faith and
they didn't buy it but anyway gentlemen
thank you so thank you so much